eu environment ministers have agreed a
common line on new rules for countries
to restrict or prohibit the cultivation
of genetically modified organisms on
their territories even if they're
authorized at european level currently
the european commission approves the
cultivation of gmos on the basis of
scientific advice and in consultation
with the european food safety authority
or fsa if the commission and efsa say no
to cultivation
it will be a no to everyone
if the commission and deficit say yes
it won't be a yes
to everyone and on specific grounds
5 10 15 20 member states can block the
cultivation on their territory the aims
to provide a legal basis to limit gmo
cultivation on grounds other than health
or environmental considerations
these could include socioeconomic
reasons land use and town planning or
agricultural and public policy
objectives
the incoming italian presidency plans to
start negotiations on the gmo package
with the newly elected european
parliament in autumn
while they're widely grown in the
americas and asia genetically modified
crops are generally unpopular in europe
environmentalists have raised concerns
about the impact on biodiversity
europe's clear air program was also up
for discussion at the council in
luxembourg the program sets limits on
harmful emissions from industry traffic
energy plants and agriculture
the ministers debated new rules on
medium-sized combustion plants which are
used for residential heating and cooling
and providing heat or steam for industry